one turbulent day Pedro Castillo went
from president of Peru to prisoner at
the country's Elite Police base
accused of attempting a coup on December
the 7th the ex-teacher from rural Peru
has since cycled through three lawyers
now the poor Ronald atencio is the
closest we've got to knowing Castillo's
thoughts apart from the few notes that
Castillo has written from prison they've
insisted that he's still the president
but atencio who visited Castillo the day
before this interview told Al Jazeera
there's been a change in his client's
position
what has he said in terms of
his imprisonment does he really expect
now to return to the presidency of the
country does he believe that that's
possible and what has he said about the
protests that have broken out after he
left the presidency
he knows there's a serious crisis 21
dead hundreds injured he's worried and
he's hurt if he has to abandon the
legitimate position the people have
given him to stop that he will
he is prepared to leave his aspirations
to return to the presidency if that
helps to end the violence
yes he is willing to make any sacrifice
for the country
that could have implications for the
protests which began after Castillo was
removed from Power
following this address to the nation
just before he was about to face an
impeachment vote in Congress the
president announced that he was going to
dissolve Congress and that he was going
to govern in a state of exception though
a government of exception
that's a coup no
for a coup to be real and concrete it
can't just be a message to the nation
there has to be a level of organization
coordination and we see that for example
that no military staff have come out to
say they were involved you didn't see
any tanks or patrols on the streets
it doesn't that just mean that it was an
unsuccessful coup that no one supported
him no we can't talk about a coup as a
coup is recognized in the world how do
you explain what he said then was it
just a mistake
I think it was definitely a political
error without any doubt why because how
do you send out a message of that
enormity without evaluating the
consequences
is now being held in prison for the next
18 months before his trial because
prosecutors say there's a Flight Risk
that's based on his actions on the 7th
of December the president of Mexico said
that he'd asked for asylum in Mexico and
it's been reported that he was on his
way to the Mexican embassy he was trying
to flee you know he was trying to leave
the country
he never called the president and said I
want Asylum he did go to the Embassy so
I think what he wanted was to look for
protection in that moment because steel
didn't make it to the Embassy attends
you say that he's now appealing against
his prison time based on the
regularities in the process to remove
him from office
but the issues at stake in Peru have now
gone beyond one man people want new
elections some want a changed
Constitution well from his prison cell
their former president has another fight
on his hands
John Holman Al Jazeera Lima